hello everyone how you guys doin' hope
you guys are having a wonderful day
today we're here with another video and
today's video will be another merging
tips video basically today I'll be going
through a bunch of items that I see that
I feel like have really low risk and
really high potential reward now a lot
of these items are going to be based on
the what happens in game whether or not
bosses are implemented and things that
Jagex can do that make items worth more
now for the most part this isn't going
to be stuff like climbing boots
you really can't prepare for stuff like
that but a few items I have in here are
items like that that need value within
the game we've seen that Jax is willing
to do this recently with stuff like
Bandos boots trying to revitalize of
those and it's definitely something that
they try to do often in the game so it's
something that as a merger you could be
prepared for and as a casual player
hopefully I can kind of convince you
into some items that could hopefully
make you money in the long term but with
that said let's get into the first item
alright so the first two items are items
that I feel like are for the most part
almost guarantees and I feel sketchy
saying that but one thing that you guys
do have to remember is these are long
terms I'm not saying this is gonna
happen within a month it could be a year
from now but these items definitely have
a lot of value when it comes to what
they could become and on top of that one
thing that I will want to say is after
this video if any of these items
skyrocket in price because of the video
please do not buy them wait it out wait
a week or two and people will slowly
start to sell them off because of the
lack of the video hype so with that said
the first item that I have here today is
it's a pretty easy one dens bulwark now
a dens bulwark right now is about 6.8
male it is an item that obviously has no
use in the game right now it's an item
that jacocks came out with in raids
obviously and they just did a terrible
job implementing it into the game
there's really no scenario in which it's
worth using and for the most part that's
why it holds a price at around 6 or 7
mil at this point really the only reason
it's holding that price is because
people think it could be useful in the
future and I to think that way as well
Jake's obviously was trying to make a
stand with this update with this item
being implemented into the game they
wanted to obviously show that defense
should matter somewhat in combat and
they weren't able to do that
successfully they just they they
butchered it and for the most part I
think that they are going to try to
reclaim that and try to make the bulwark
useful in the future
because really you can't have an item
like that come into the game and then be
dead content right away now I mean
they've done it with other things but
obviously here they're trying to aim for
more of a defensive combat system or at
least one thing that could be defensive
and I think that they might try to
revitalize it in the future
with that said as far as risk on this
item I do think there is a little bit of
risk it's probably one of the riskier
items in this video because of the fact
that it's six to seven mil and it
doesn't have six or seven mil value for
most players the only reason it's there
as I said earlier is because of the
potential value and I feel like some
people actually see that and it
definitely is an item that doesn't come
into the game a lot but the only reason
it's priced that low is because of its
lack of use if it's ever given any
little bit of a use it will skyrocket
next up is an item that I feel like is
just I mean it's it's almost too obvious
to the point where I feel like jagex
thinks too many people are already
invested in it and I was personally
invested into it up until about two
weeks ago and that is red wood logs red
wood logs are just they're an anomaly
within the game they're used for fire
making people don't even want to do
those logs with fire making now the way
that I feel like these could go up is if
regular fire making is made more FK
bonfires but I mean for the most part
these I mean red wood logs are a ninety
wood cutting requirement granted they're
camped pretty heavily but no one wants
to actually train fire making they
obviously are gonna keep a decent price
at around 300 because for the people
that are max efficiently red wood logs
are better than winter tot however the
regular player it's really not worth it
what I see going forward is either red
wood logs are given a fletching update
or there's going to be some sort of way
to do fire making with logs that'll be a
little bit more afk and allow people to
want to actually use red logs in the
future as I said before I don't think
there's a whole lot of risk with this
item there's a really high requirement
to be able to get it with ninety wood
cutting while it is camped pretty
heavily as I said before people do use
these at high levels that are trying to
be max efficient and you are always
gonna have people that are invested in
these for the same reasons I'm stating
now going into the next one now the next
one is not a high-risk item at the time
of recording it's around 1,000 coins so
definitely something keep an eye on now
I tried I tried pushing this in the past
and it never ended up working out but
Slayer enchantments are dropped from
wilderness Slayer and obviously they're
pretty easy to get and I don't know if
Jax will ever come back on these but I
feel like it's very easy to say that an
item that's worth 1k that's very hard to
get is a drop it's not something you can
go out and get easily obviously if
you're doing wilderness Slayer passively
then you can get a decent amount of them
but very few people do wilderness Slayer
and if these things are ever given any
little bit of a use to where they go up
to 5 to 10 K potentially I mean that's a
500 2,000 percent return on whatever you
invested and really there's no risk of
it going below 1,000 I mean for the most
part there are going to be some people
buying it and you probably won't have
any real scare as far as it goes right
now now personally I invested in these
whenever they were 8 to 9 K obviously a
fail in that regard but I mean you never
know what could happen in the future now
on top of that I'm gonna go ahead and
group these two kind of in the same
category because I feel like it is the
same thing essentially so basically one
is going to be warrior rings /
treasonous rings both of these rings
really cheap for what they do
they both gain accuracy and Jay X
obviously hasn't seen accuracy as being
that important now all these items have
been in the game for a while and have
continued to drop in price you
eventually get to the point where they
can't drop much more because they come
into the game so seldomly that people
will be willing to invest in them just
in case
and even if Jay X doesn't decide
necessarily to go and make these rings
better they could potentially put
monsters into the game in the future
that do require a lot higher accuracy
rather than a better strength bonus now
that's something that you're gambling on
of course but with all of these
merchants that is a thing that is going
to be there now with that as well I
would like to add dragon axis dragon
axes are 45 K they're high out price is
30 K so the most you're losing on this
is a third of your money and that is
that's ridiculous because they're going
to be higher than 30 K because people
are going to want to have them I mean
it's an item in the game that I get I
understand comes into the game at a very
heavy rate through Dagon off kings but
stuff that we see such as a bit
so whips other items of the sort are
meant to degrade over time and
eventually I feel like that's something
that they could implement with dragon
axes now while I do understand that
dragon axes have already had smoldering
stones be able to be added on to them
you do have to realize that there have
been no better axes added in the game
and this is a method that Jagex likes to
go about getting regular items out of
the game that come in too frequently
they did this with whips obviously and
they've done that a ton before they try
to get items out of the game and dragon
axes obviously have this problem now Jax
hasn't done anything up until this point
so they may not do anything going
forward but do not fear there are other
ways that dragon axes do go up whenever
there's wood cutting or fire making
updates in the case of winter taht you
can see dragon axes prices go up about
double - even sometimes triple depending
on what time you get it at and really
even if you end up going up double
that's a ton of money compared to what
you invested into it and just for a wood
cutting update of sum or something of
the sort that could come out relatively
often now when I say relatively often I
mean you know once every year or two but
relative to how much you're investing
and you're returning two times the
profit it's something that definitely
could be worth it to you the next items
I have aren't as reliant on a JX update
which could be good for you depending on
what you're able to do basically
something I've noticed in the game and
something that I mean I definitely
already missed the boat on but they're
still a boat waiting it's just not as
good of a boat but this one is going to
be malediction shards and odium shards
basically just buying the cheapest ones
in this case malediction shards one
right now are 100k you know decently
high for what they've been in the past
but I mean in the past they've gone up
to five to six hundred K whenever
they're in high demand the same thing
goes for odium shards three typically
the hardest one to get however the
cheapest right now just because people
are probably camping them a little bit
more than odium shards one and two now
with that said the reason that these
shards and the cheaper shards of the
bunch are going to go up in price is
because whenever odium wards and
malediction wards go up for whatever
reason it could because of anything in
the game people can make money by
putting these shards together and
they're typically willing to pay a lot
of money for the shards that cost the
lease because really I mean paying
another 50k for a hundred K shard isn't
going to hurt your overall profit if
you're making 200
okay but for the person merging it you
just made a 50% profit on whatever you
invested in that shard and if you bought
a ton of these you can definitely make a
lot of money on them also with that
these shards are not actively traded at
all so they have potential to vary so
widely I've seen some that have gone
just 300 400 sometimes even like a mil
higher than they should just because
there's none on the market and if you
really really need it for whatever
you're doing or if you just want to
check the margins and someone
accidentally buys it you can definitely
get away with selling some of these for
insane profits now this isn't going to
be reliant on a jazz update as I said
before but it's something that's almost
guaranteed to happen at some point in
the future there won't be enough on the
market to supply the people at needle a
little warning though as I did just say
they're not very actively traded so if
you try to buy them after this video
they may have gone up a lot in price and
I would say don't invest in them right
after this video but keep them in your
back pocket and here we are time for the
last one now this is not really reliant
on a specific update in general but zora
scales I feel like are just a almost a
lock to be able to make money Zhora
obviously with the recent nerf I mean so
where skills are at a 120 g p they've
definitely gone higher in the past and
they could just be a good investment say
as is right now but one thing that you
have to consider going forward is over
skills are vital and pretty much the
best DPS things within the game toxic
blow pipe obviously SERP helm and also
with a trident but basically you're
going to needs or skills almost
throughout what seems to be the entirety
of the game however long this game is
going to go on for the most part at
least within the next couple years you
would imagine that the ZOA items will be
the most beneficial for whatever you're
doing and thus you're going to need
scales but over the next few years
jaggus is going to release money making
methods better than Zora well I know
that may come as a shock but if they've
already released raids they've announced
raids - which are going to be better
than one I would presume but who knows
and on the side of that there are going
to be money making methods that pop up
whether through updates or just in-game
changes that happen and with that said
less people are going to be motivated to
do ZOA
because they've already been grinding it
for years at this point it's pretty much
become a bore and if you have better
money making methods anyways you're not
going to want to do it thus causing the
price of Zoeller skills to rise
because the scale prices are going to
have to match the economy and the needs
of the market and if people keep needing
these scales eventually they're gonna
have to go up to the point where Zola is
still a competitive money making method
to other high-level methods in the
future now this is something that's
highly speculative but something I
definitely do believe in and would
recommend you guys invest if you want to
make money going forward now with that
said that'll be the end of this video so
hopefully you guys enjoyed some things I
want to go ahead and say right away is
these are meant to be long-term merges
don't come back to this video within two
months and say yeah that didn't work
didn't work I didn't make any money you
suck I mean I get it I get it you want
to make money off the items that I give
you but long-term I feel like almost all
of these items are going to work it's
just a matter of having them when they
do so you don't even need to invest
right after this video you can just
write them down build up some Bank
whenever you get some cash on the side
and you want to invest go ahead and
throw them into these they don't really
have potential for a lot of loss other
than the bull work I think and for the
most part they can only really go up and
if you hit it you'll hit it big so
hopefully you guys enjoyed it if you
guys did make sure to leave a like
there's anything you want to tell me go
ahead and comment down below if you guys
enjoy my content and want to see it as
soon as it goes live make sure to hit
that sub button but with that said
hopefully you guys have a wonderful day
and peace and check out the Twitter and
the description down below
[Music]